prince maegor a warrior who was proud
and arrogant maeger agreed to marry the
high septon's niece
to unite the faith and the crown but
then
secretly weared a second wife in a
valerian ceremony artfully combining
bigamy and heresy
when word of it got out the king was
forced to exile maegor and choose a
septon as his new hand
but the damage had been done the king
had trusted in family
and his brother had set off a rebellion
that would claim his rule
and his life but when aegon's heir
wedded his daughter to his son
the faith could brook such abomination
no longer
the high septon led the denunciation of
the targaryens
and all over westeros the faith militant
took up their swords against the dynasty
and its supporters the faith militant
set upon and punished the septon who had
performed the ceremony
a few of the faith militants more
militant
members even scaled the walls of the
castle
and would have slain the king and his
family had a night of the king's guard
not intervened frightened the king fled
to dragonstone
where he soon died of craps and so
ascended the king's younger brother
maegor
the cruel his first act was to challenge
the faith militant to kill him
if they believed his rule to be ungodly
to the order's eternal credit
they accepted sir damon morrigan
proposed a trial by seven said damon and
six of the faith militant
against the king and his six champions
it was a contest in which the kingdom
itself was at stake
and the accounts and tales are many
but at the end of it maegor alone
lived proving that the throne was
rightfully his
he mounted the black dragon valerian
and burnt down the sept in king's
landing while the faith militant were
inside
at morning prayers the screams of the
burning
and dying men were said to echo
throughout the city
omega had won the trial by seven he
demanded the complete destruction of the
faith militant
and the faith itself if necessary he
made war upon the order
wherever he found it yet the faith
militant would not
surrender raising armies of their own
and turning mega's own lords against him
the father's justice may not always be
swift
but it is certain one morning mega was
found dead on the iron throne
no one knows how after the conquest when
men looked up
they saw dragons nobles learned to keep
their eyes down
but the gods weren't used to sharing the
heavens
when aegon died the high septon led to
the faith
and its army in revolt claiming that the
valyrian tradition of wedding brother to
sister was an abomination in the eyes of
the seven
though no one could explain where the
divine mother and father had come from
my ancestor make all the wise who make
all the cruel as men slander him
put a bounty on the head of every
militant priest
and miraculously the faith soon returned
to the sects
though the targaryens had forged the
seven kingdoms in
fire and blood they didn't govern with
them
until they did magel first of his name
defined council as confirmation and
disagreement as treason
three grand maesters tried to avert
disaster
instead of taking their advice maegor
took their heads
as a second son and exile maegor was
never meant to rule
but no sooner did maker hear of his
brother's death then he flew valerian to
dragonstone and demanded
the crown only the grand maester dared
object that the throne should pass to
his older brother's firstborn son prince
aegon
magor insisted that the iron throne
should go to the man with the strength
to seize it
and beheaded the grand maester prince
aegon
soon took him at his word he claimed his
father's dragon
raised a host of western men and marched
on king's landing while maegor was in
old town
far from the capital magor couldn't
rally an army to match aegon's
so he ordered his banis to swarm aegon's
larger army from all sides
confusing the young prince and slowing
his advance
beneath the gods eye maegor's disparate
forces came together and attacked aegon
as
maegor himself swooped down from the
clouds
for the first time since the doom of
valyria dragon fought dragon in the sky
that aegon's dragon was no match for
valerian the dread
who was four times its size when aegon
fell to his death
his army broke and fled for slaying his
own nephew may go forever after became
known as
the cruel though of course not to his
face
the next grand maester dared object to
make or taking a third wife
when taking his second wife had ruined
his brother's reign
because mega's first wife was the niece
of the high septon
but mega beheaded the grand maester and
declared war on the faith
he set fire to the riverlands the
westerlands and the reach in a campaign
to root out disloyal lords
and sponsored a more pliant high septon
none of it worked maego may have
returned to the capitol with 2 000
skulls of the faith militant but most of
them weren't
soldiers they were simple folk who had
sheltered the outlaw septons
or turned out in droves to hear them
denounce the wicked king
the third grand maester dared to declare
maegor the father of his own heir but
when his second wife miscarried
and maegor saw the monstrous stillbirth
mago beheaded the grand maester for his
insolent adherence to truth
so he had no one to warn him when his
third wife
sensing an advantage declared that his
second wife had been unfaithful
and produced a list of potential fathers
of the misshapen child
not only did maegor execute his second
wife and her father
his own hand of the king but he also
marched on her family's castle and
slaughtered everyone who bore a drop of
her family's blood
but his third wife couldn't give him a
child
either desperate to cement his stolen
throne with an
hair maego took three wives at once
known as the black brides because
each were women he'd widowed in his wars
all three women grew full with child in
time
but each gave birth to the same twisted
monstrosities as his second wife
one need not be a maester much less a
grand maester to deduce the common
thread here
though maegor stamped out the fires of
rebellion his cruelty and fear only
scattered more tinder over the realm
until even the smallest ember could set
the realm of light
one day the faith militant emerged from
the shadows and the lord
sent to quash it joined it instead his
hand resigned and retired to his island
home
finally house baratheon declared for
mega's own nephew as the rightful king
the lannisters tyrells and aarons soon
joined
adding more than half the might of
westeros to the prince and his two
dragons
which became three when maegor's niece
and involuntary black bride
stole away from the red keep with her
dragon her treason wasn't even the last
mega's own lord admiral sailed the royal
fleet into his nephew's harbour
but most fitting of all when maegor
tried to send ravens to call his banners
he found that his fourth grand maester
had learned
from his predecessors and fled
maegor spent one final night on the iron
throne
he was found in the morning with his
wrists slashed
and one of the thrones blades jutting
from his throat
nobody knows if he was one of his queens
or king's guard
or one of the thousands who wanted him
dead or even maegor himself
frustrated that his body had failed his
will
whoever the culprit no doubt he died as
all tyrants do
believing that history would vindicate
him it hasn't
history may be written with fire and
blood but histories
aren't as any good advisor
could have warned him when the builders
finally finished the red keep
maegor executed them all to keep its
secrets safe
rumor has it miles of hidden passageways
run behind the walls
and under the floors one day i'll have
to find them
traitors and women work in shadows
a king has no need for secrecy
now people named magog the cruel
but i doubt any dared in his day his
strength was all too rare in the
degenerate targaryen
blood and maegor decided to replace a
monument to the gods
with a monument to his family the dragon
pit
labor proved elusive however for after
the red keep was finished
maegor had hosted a three-day feast for
all the builders stonemasons and
carpenters
who had worked to build it at its
conclusion
he slaughtered them so that only he
would know the castle secrets
so many men fled the construction of the
dragonpit
but maegor was forced to employ the
prisoners of the city dungeons
supplemented by skilled and ignorant
builders
from across the narrow sea aegon's own
son
maegor the cruel was killed by the very
iron throne his father had forged
if you believe the tales if you don't
then perhaps the cruel is not a wise
name for a king to earn
[Music]
you